what's going on Jason role dog and I
were coming out coming out of the house
today start our ride and I was like hey
roll check this out
what's up with that first time ever I've
been able to get out of the saddle that
whatever riding bite ever since your
accident ever you know everybody that
anybody's ever been able to get your
your feet your butt off the seat anybody
that knows me that's talking with me
they've never seen me out of my saddle
climbing a hill God's got your back
check this out come down this hill with
me real quick previous video I was
telling you how I've never been able to
reach down and grab my water bottle to
drink in a race we roll dog and I were
just getting ready to go on our ride
today and we just found out that I could
actually get out of my seat
all my clients and every single race and
all my training sessions sit in the
saddle
Hill